Es ecléctica, lo sé,
desde aerogeneradores en tierra hasta la educación de las niñas,
desde dietas ricas en plantas hasta tecnología solar en los techos.
Así que, desglosemos un poco.
A la derecha de la diapositiva, verán cifras en gigatoneladas,
o miles de millones de toneladas.
Eso representa el equivalente total de dióxido de carbono
reducido de la atmósfera,
cuando la solución se implemente globalmente en un período de 30 años.
Ahora, cuando pensamos en soluciones climáticas,
a menudo pensamos en la generación de electricidad.
Pensamos en la energía renovable
como el conjunto de soluciones más importante,
y son increíblemente importantes.
Pero, lo primero que se debe notar sobre esta lista
es que sólo cinco de las 20 soluciones principales
se relacionan con la electricidad.
Lo que honestamente nos sorprendió,
fue que 8 de los 20 se relacionan con el sistema alimentario.
El impacto climático de los alimentos
puede ser una sorpresa para muchas personas,
pero lo que muestran estos resultados
es que las decisiones que tomamos todos los días
sobre los alimentos que producimos, compramos y consumimos
son quizás las contribuciones más importantes
que todos los individuos pueden hacer para revertir el calentamiento global.
Y el cómo manejamos el suelo también es muy importante.
La protección de los bosques y salvaguardar los humedales,
expande y crea nuevos sumideros de carbono
que reducen directamente el carbono.
Así es como puede ocurrir la reducción.
Y cuando juntamos la administración de alimentos y suelos
12 de las 20 soluciones principales
se relacionan con cómo y por qué usamos el suelo.
Esto cambia fundamentalmente el pensamiento tradicional
sobre las soluciones climáticas.
Pero vayamos a la parte superior de la lista,
porque creo que lo que hay allí también puede sorprenderlos.
La solución más impactante,
según este análisis, sería la gestión de la refrigeración
o la gestión y eliminación adecuadas de los hidrofluorocarbonos,
también conocidos como HFC,
los cuales son utilizados por los refrigeradores
y aires acondicionados para enfriar el aire.
Hicimos un gran trabajo con el Protocolo de Montreal
para limitar la producción de clorofluorocarbonos, CFC,
debido a su efecto en la capa de ozono.
Pero fueron reemplazados por HFC,
que son cientos a miles de veces más potentes
como gas de efecto invernadero que el dióxido de carbono.
Y esas 90 gigatoneladas reducidas es una cifra conservadora.
Si tuviéramos que explicar el impacto del acuerdo de Kigali de 2016,
el cual exige la eliminación gradual de los hidrofluorocarbonos
y reemplazarlos por refrigerantes naturales que existen actualmente,
este número podría aumentar a 120, a casi 200 gigatoneladas
de gases de efecto invernadero evitados.
Tal vez estén sorprendidos, tal y como lo estábamos nosotros.
Ahora, antes de entrar en algunos detalles de soluciones específicas,
puede que se estén preguntando cómo llegamos a estos cálculos.
En primer, lugar recopilamos una gran cantidad de datos
y utilizamos el análisis estadístico para crear rangos
que nos permiten elegir opciones razonables
para cada entrada utilizada en los modelos.
Y elegimos un enfoque conservador, que subyace a todo el proyecto.
Todos los datos se ingresan en el modelo,
se proyectan de forma ambiciosa pero plausible hacia el futuro
y se comparan con lo que tendríamos que hacer de todos modos.
Las 84 gigatoneladas reducidos de las turbinas eólicas terrestres, por ejemplo,
resultan de la electricidad generada por las instalaciones eólicas
que de otra forma se producirían a partir de plantas de carbón o de gas.
Calculamos todos los costos para construir y operar las plantas
y todas las emisiones generadas.
El mismo proceso se usa para comparar el reciclaje frente al relleno sanitario,
la agricultura regenerativa frente a la industrial,
la protección frente a la tala de nuestros bosques.
Luego, los resultados se integran dentro de los sistemas y entre sí,
para evitar el doble conteo
y sumarlos para ver si realmente podemos reducirlos.
Bueno, vamos a entrar en algunas soluciones específicas.
La energía solar en techos ocupa el puesto número 10.
Cuando imaginamos la energía solar de techos en nuestra mente,
a menudo imaginamos un almacén en Miami cubierto de paneles solares.
Pero estas son soluciones relevantes en entornos urbanos y rurales,
países de ingresos altos y bajos
y tienen beneficios en cascada.
Esta es una familia en una isla de paja en el lago Titicaca,
que recibe su primer panel solar.
Antes, el queroseno se usaba para cocinar e iluminar;
el queroseno en una isla de paja.
Así que, al instalar energía solar,
esta familia no sólo está ayudando a reducir las emisiones,
sino que también brinda seguridad y protección a sus hogares.
Y los bosques tropicales cuentan su propia historia.
Proteger la tierra actualmente degradada en los trópicos
y permitir que ocurra la regeneración natural
es la solución número cinco para revertir el calentamiento global.
Podemos pensar en los árboles como gigantescas varas de carbono.
Esta es reducción en acción cada año,
ya que el carbono se elimina de la atmósfera a través de la fotosíntesis,
la cual convierte el dióxido de carbono
en biomasa de las plantas y carbono orgánico del suelo.
Y tenemos que repensar cómo producimos nuestros alimentos
para hacerlos más regenerativos.
Hay muchas maneras de hacer esto, e investigamos más de 13 de ellas,
pero estas no son nuevas formas de producir alimentos.
Se han practicado durante siglos, durante generaciones,
pero cada vez más son desplazadas por la agricultura moderna
que promueve la labranza, el monocultivo
y el uso de fertilizantes sintéticos y pesticidas que degradan el suelo
y la convierten en un emisor neto de gases de efecto invernadero.
Por otro lado, la agricultura regenerativa
restaura la salud y la productividad del suelo,
aumenta el rendimiento,
mejora la retención de agua,
beneficia a los pequeños agricultores
y las grandes operaciones agrícolas por igual
y devuelve el carbono al suelo.
Es un ganar-ganar-ganar
ganar-ganar.
(Risas)
Y no es sólo la forma como producimos alimentos,
sino lo que consumimos
lo que tiene un impacto masivo en el calentamiento global.
Una dieta rica en plantas no es una dieta vegana o vegetariana,
aunque aplaudo a cualquiera que tome esas decisiones.
Es una dieta saludable en términos de cuánto consumimos
y en particular, de cuánta carne se consume.
En las partes más ricas del mundo,
consumimos en exceso.
Sin embargo, los países de bajos ingresos
muestran una ingesta insuficiente de calorías y proteínas.
Eso requiere un reequilibrio
y es en el rebalanceo
que una dieta rica en plantas se convierte en la solución No. 4
para revertir el calentamiento global.
Además, casi un tercio de los alimentos producidos no se consumen
y los alimentos desperdiciados emiten
un asombroso 8 % de los gases de efecto invernadero a nivel mundial.
Necesitamos ver dónde se producen estas pérdidas
y desperdicios en toda la cadena de suministro.
En los países de bajos ingresos,
después de que los alimentos salen de la granja,
la mayoría se desperdicia al comienzo de la cadena de suministro
por los desafíos de infraestructura y almacenamiento.
El alimento no se desperdicia en países de bajos ingresos
que sufren para alimentar a su población.
En cambio, en el mundo desarrollado
luego de que el alimento sale de la granja
la mayoría se desperdicia al final de la cadena de suministro
por los mercados y consumidores
y los desperdicios terminan en el relleno sanitario donde emiten metano
mientras se descompone.
Este es un problema de elección del consumidor.
No es un problema de tecnología.
Prevenir el desperdicio de alimentos desde el principio es la solución No. 3
Pero aquí está lo interesante.
Cuando observamos el sistema alimentario en su totalidad
e implementamos todas las soluciones de producción,
como la agricultura regenerativa
y adoptamos una dieta rica en plantas
y reducimos el desperdicio de alimentos,
nuestra investigación muestra
que produciríamos alimentos suficientes en las tierras agrícolas actuales,
para alimentar la creciente población del mundo
con una dieta saludable y rica en nutrientes hasta 2050 y más allá.
Esto es que no necesitamos talar bosques para producir alimento.
Las soluciones para revertir el calentamiento global
son las mismas soluciones para la inseguridad alimentaria.
Ahora, una solución de la que a menudo no se habla lo suficiente
es la planificación familiar.
Al proporcionar a hombres y mujeres el derecho a elegir
cuándo, cómo y si criar a una familia
a través de clínicas de salud reproductiva y educación,
acceso a la anticoncepción
y la libertad sin persecución
pueden reducir la población mundial estimada para 2050.
Esa reducción de la población significa una menor demanda
de electricidad, comida, viajes, edificios y todos los demás recursos.
Toda la energía y las emisiones que se usan para producir esa mayor demanda
se reducen al proporcionar el derecho humano básico
a elegir cuándo, cómo y si criar una familia.
Pero la planificación familiar no puede darse
sin una educación de igual calidad
para las niñas, a las que actualmente se les niega el acceso.
Ahora, nos hemos tomado una pequeña libertad aquí,
porque el impacto de la educación universal
y los recursos de planificación familiar
están entrelazados de manera tan inseparable
que decidimos cortarla por la mitad.
Pero en conjunto, educar a las niñas y la planificación familiar
es la solución número uno para revertir el calentamiento global,
que reduce casi 120 mil millones de toneladas de gases de efecto invernadero.
Entonces, ¿es posible la reducción?
La respuesta es sí, es posible,
pero necesitamos las 80 soluciones.
No hay varitas mágicas o un subconjunto de soluciones.
Las mejores soluciones nos llevarán a lo largo del camino,
pero no existe una solución pequeña.
Necesitamos todas las 80.
Pero, esta es la gran cuestión.
Nos gustaría implementar estas soluciones
ya sea que el calentamiento global haya sido un problema o no,
dado que tienen beneficios en cascada para el bienestar humano y planetario.
La electricidad renovable da como resultado un acceso limpio
y abundante de energía para todos.
Una dieta rica en plantas y una reducción en el desperdicio de alimento,
da como resultado una población global sana con suficiente alimento y sustento.
¿Planificación familiar y educación de las niñas?
Esto se trata de derechos humanos,
de igualdad de género.
Se trata de la mejora económica y la libertad de elección.
Se trata de justicia.
La agricultura regenerativa, el pastoreo administrado, la agrosilvicultura;
la silvopastura restaura la salud del suelo,
beneficia a los agricultores y devuelve el carbono al suelo.
La protección de nuestros ecosistemas también protege la biodiversidad
y preserva la salud planetaria
y el oxígeno que respiramos.
Sus beneficios tangibles para todas las especies son incalculables.
Por último, porque sé que quizá todos lo están pensando:
¿cuánto va a costar?
Bueno, estimamos que implementar las 80 soluciones
costaría alrededor de 29 billones de USD en 30 años.
Eso es casi un billón al año.
Ahora, sé que suena a un montón,
pero recordemos que el PIB global supera USD 80 billones cada año
y el ahorro estimado al implementar estas soluciones
es de 74 billones de dólares, más del doble de los costos.
Eso es un ahorro neto de 44 billones de dólares.
Así que, la reducción es posible.
Podemos hacerlo si queremos.
No va a costar mucho y el retorno de esa inversión es enorme.
Aquí está la grata sorpresa.
Cuando implementamos estas soluciones,
cambiamos la forma en que hacemos negocios
de un sistema que es intrínsecamente explotador y extractivo,
a una nueva normalidad: restaurativa y regenerativa por naturaleza.
Necesitamos repensar nuestros objetivos globales,
ir más allá de la sostenibilidad
hacia la regeneración,
y en el camino revertir el calentamiento global.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)